[Music]
we are here to talk about horizon zero
dawn it is the new third person action
open-world game from guerrilla games the
guys make kill zone it is a ps4
exclusive I actually got to play a
little bit of this back at e3 2016 so we
still have all of that coverage on the
site but we now actually have new
footage new gameplay trailers all this
different kind of stuff that's going up
on the site today but you went and
played the game down in la recently so
can you tell us a little bit about your
hands on experience what you got to play
just broadly yeah I got to play about
four and a half hours I actually got to
put the opening section of the game
where I presume is the opening so you'd
see a loi as a little girl and plays her
and get a lot of story set up and
flushes out a little bit of the story
trailers we've gotten and then we
skipped ahead to a later section of the
game to get access to you know better
weapons and more hardcore enemies that's
really interesting to hear that you got
to play as a lawyer as a child I didn't
know that that's how they were
approaching things so like what can you
tell us about the story and what you got
to see so far we've only had this one
narrative trailer that doesn't really
tell us all that much right yeah so
basically the setup and I would say it's
a little cliche it's a matriarchal
society you don't know who Aloise mother
is which is of course a big problem
there's a goddess so it's a little bit
you know I've seen that sort of setup
before sounds a little cheesy yeah it
can be the dialogue to be a little
cheesy but it does set up kind of her
motivations and that was what was
important to me because I really like
her as a character and I got to know a
little bit more about her and why she
wants to hunt and do the things she's
doing I'm and then one Scene really
stuck out to me which was your kind of
down in the metal world if you don't
know horizon is sort of this post post
apocalyptic world about a thousand years
in the future so there's like ancient
machinery and she goes into the metal
world and she sees Holograms and like
memories of the people who were there
before and sees a father wishing his son
happy birthday and we didn't get to
capture this but it stuck out to me so
much because she acts so much like a
child she's supposed to be six and she's
repeating the words back and you know
she doesn't really have a family she
says outcast and so that balanced out
cheesier elements for me I thought that
was a really good moment with her and I
really like the setup and I got to know
her a little bit better well it's
encouraging that they're taking the time
to set up this character because if you
do that
at the beginning of the game then
hopefully everything that happens after
that will be a little more impactful
ways you can kind of know this character
exactly you're lucky I happened by one
heartbeat more and that sawtooth would
have torn you apart half a heartbeat
more and I would have killed it myself
uh so you're Warchief sona Laurel asked
me to find you has he held the gate he
has so you also got to play some game
play you mentioned at the beginning
there was a bunch of stuff you got to
play later in the game so what can you
tell us about the combat loop and sort
of what you got to play of the game yeah
I really enjoyed the combat loop it was
satisfying there's a lot of different
ways to approach combat so you're
basically hunting these machines you can
harvest them for parts and there's
quests around it I really liked kind of
staying back and being stealthy there's
also really cool stealth kills where you
can just basically stab a machine in the
neck and it goes down why not so you
know why not it was cool and it was
really satisfying to execute especially
the stealth sections you have sort of
this device that looks like a wearable
bluetooth a device that lets you scan
your environment you can also track
enemies so you can see it highlights
where an enemy that has sort of a path
that it follows sure you can see what
that path isn't either sneak past it or
plant trip mines and trip it up and then
take it down from there and a lot of
different options and the skill tree
ties into that you get to unlock
different ways to take down enemies or
to be stealthy ER and so I I really
found it satisfying especially in the
context of the open world I can kind of
just track down whatever monster I
wanted to just quickly how deep would
you say the skill tree is I mean does it
really branch are there a lot of
different playstyles like how deep are
we going here um there's a there's three
main branches there's I think prowler
brave and it's like forager or harvester
something like that and so there's the 3
gameplay types in them within that they
branch and so it's pretty decently deep
I mean not the deepest skill tree I've
ever seen but there were a lot of
different options like you know stealthy
drops or now you loot more items from
the courses of monsters gotcha
so was there anything in the demo that
you didn't enjoy that you think still
needs may be a little bit of work before
the game is actually out I would say the
camera is the wonky esparto vit you have
to remember gorilla has a history of
first-person and so I kind of took that
into account the transition from first
to third can be weird but if you've ever
played a third person game and you moved
the camera and got a face full of tree
or a zoom in on a wall yeah that's sort
of the thing we're talking about so that
happened sort of frequently more
frequently than I would have wanted but
not in a way that totally obstructed my
exploration of the world or my ability
to take down enemies but I I would like
to see that cleaned up a little bit
gotcha overall the what was your
impression of games and what feeling
positive for pretty much or feel a
little concerned I mean how you feeling
about the guy in general I'm really
excited to play more honestly I loved
the RPG elements I want to know more
about a boy as a character and I want to
follow her journey through you know
figuring out what her origin is and I'm
interested to learn more about that and
I really did find the combat really
engaging and I wanted to keep playing
awesome well I'm excited about this game
myself so I'm hoping that it all comes
together hoping they can fix the camera
shoes still a little bit of time before
release so stay tuned to gamespot com
we're going to continue to cover this
one and give you more updates be sure to
check out our 4k footage of the game our
gameplay highlights and Callie's written
impressions and yeah staging gamespot
com for all your video game needs
you